[Musique]
bonjour
moi c'est ma robe est arrivé ja oui on a
bien sûr je suis contente oui mais ces
groupes
deux bouteilles
la maman
ou
alors là tant elle a un sens
là
comme la reine d'angleterre voilà
tout de suite le changement d'état en
fait l'europe dès que vous m'aidiez la
robe ça y est vous changer les
paramètres s'inquiète entre l'hôpital
vous êtes quelqu'un d'autre bon elle me
va bien cette fois vous en faites et je
pensais qu'il fallait mettre à tout prix
des talons hauts mais non je m'aperçois
que en fait avec des talons plats savez
bien aussi de considérer ce avec quoi je
travaille en fait dans la mode donc j'ai
des considérations de mode d'entrée
temps réponse est non mais avec les
talons plats ça va t-il
voilà
[Musique]
juge au tribunal de commerce
si on m'avait dit un jour que je
porterai cette robe que j'endosse ray
cette responsabilité moi qui ne connais
rien au droit ni à la justice je me suis
lancé dans une aventure un peu folle
aujourd'hui c'est la rentrée du tribunal
de marseille je vais officiellement
devenir juge
[Musique]
alors victoire avait ressorti de mon
côté
je ne
parmi les 80 jugent les plus aguerris
sont là depuis 15 ans là ça fait bien et
nous ne sommes que mes fans
mais là nous sommes à vue pour un mandat
de quatre ans renouvelable trois fois et
nous ne sommes pas payés nous sommes
bénévoles
[Musique]
dans cet univers pétri de conventions je
vais devoir faire ma place
c'est parti pour une longue journée
d'intronisation
a donc il faut sortir
madame bonjour bonjour monsieur
bon
je
c'est sa fac et des femmes
havas okoumé
beauchamp vous êtes présidente de
chambre je suis dit ce président
il ya tout un tas de code on va
apprendre les codes
à la porte sous faulx mesdames offert
mais
mesdames et messieurs les nouveaux juges
je vous souhaite la bienvenue dans ce
tribunal dont vous faites partie dès cet
instant et je vous invite à rejoindre
les places qui vous sont réservées
auprès de vos collègues
déclarons les nouveaux juges installé
le tribunal de commerce c'est la justice
des entreprises nous ne sommes pas des
juges professionnels nous sommes tous
chefs d'entreprise ou cadres dirigeants
et nous jugeons nos pères ce modèle est
unique au monde la loi va essayer de
procéder rapide présentation je vais
d'abord commencé
par des cinq petits nouveaux c'est à
dire ceux qui n'ont jamais jusqu'à
présent été élu dans un tribunal de
commerce et donc pour laquelle pour
lesquels c'est véritablement aujourd'hui
leur installation
alors monsieur gossip il est marié il a
quatre enfants comme c'est un garçon va
dire son âge il a 66 ans il a passé une
grande partie de sa vie dans des grandes
entreprises de bâtiment dans des
fonctions de juriste de gestion de
communication et de ressources humaines
c'est à l'ancien chasseur alpin qui
pratiquent le ski et la marche à pied
julien il est marié là trois enfants il
a 47 ans alors julien il pratique le
tennis et le golf ça c'est vraiment très
bien ça nous fait un participant de plus
pour notre tournoi de golf au mois de
septembre
catherine de pollini
[Musique]
catherine dispose d'une maîtrise en
marketing et ventes
elle est gérante de la société le mât de
l'âme et exerce une activité de conseil
en communication spécialisée sur les
produits de luxe catherine gère
également une ligne de prêt à porter
féminin qui s'appelle follement
classique
et dynamique mais pas sportif dit elle
et elle consacre beaucoup de temps des
mollahs la preuve
catherine je te sois très bienvenu
d'autant plus que tu est affecté comme
tu le sais dans ma chambre et j'espère
que nous ferons bon travail ensemble
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes très très loin de ce tsunami
ou de cette vague de défaillances
d'entreprises que les observateurs de la
vie économique nous promettent depuis le
mois de juin 2001 pour autant ne semble
pas que nous puissions nous en réjouir
et les entreprises sont aujourd'hui
comme en apnée sous perfusion voir
anesthésié par les reports de paiement
de loyer ou de charge les pge et toutes
ces aides publiques qui lorsqu'ils
auront été octroyés
mais pourtant le réveil risque d'être
douloureux lorsqu'il faudra faire face à
ses dettes dont on repousse l'échéance
depuis plusieurs mois tribunal de
commerce il prépare activement mais il
est également force de proposition
g
je jure et promet de bien et fidèlement
remplir mes fonctions
de garder le secret des délibérations
et de me conduire en tout comme un juge
digne et loyal
catherine de pollini gérer gère
rendre la justice au nom du peuple
français c'est avant tout dire le droit
trancher les litiges en toute
indépendance la déontologie doit être
une préoccupation constante de tous
juges
pour devenir juge c'est un grand
cérémonial
le même depuis plusieurs siècles
c'est à marseille en l'an xiv 155 que
pour la première fois des commerçants
sont devenus juges pour réguler le monde
des affaires
la paix soit avec vous
particularité du tribunal de commerce de
marseille il y a toujours une messe de
rentrée c'est la tradition plutôt
original pour une institution laïque
l'idée est de nous transmettre l'esprit
de vérité et d'équité pour nous aider à
rendre la justice
notre
[Musique]
chers amis
continuez à vous laisser habiter par
l'amour du bien public dans un esprit de
désintéressement
[Musique]
le tribunal de commerce est un univers
élitiste il faut pouvoir y consacrer du
temps et ce bénévolement
je suis au tribunal de commerce de
marseille parce que ça m'a intéressé on
donnait suis dit tiens ça correspond ce
que je suis ça correspond à ce que j'ai
envie de faire mais ça correspond aussi
à aller se mettre dans la société dire
où je suis là à quoi je peux comment je
peux contribuer en fait mais en même
temps parce qu'il faut quand même être
un peu honnête en même temps en faisant
quelque chose qui m'intéresse ce que ça
va intéresser c'est très intéressant
le tribunal de commerce intervient dans
toute la vie de l'entreprise à partir de
sa création jusqu'à sa fermeture
qu'elle soit volontaire ou pas il est là
pour l'aider à passer le cap des
difficultés qu'elle rencontre et il est
là pour les litiges entre entreprises
je suis sylvain ruffier je suis juge
depuis bientôt 12 ans j'ai 43 ans
[Musique]
comme tous les juges consulaires
tribunaux de commerce on est avant tout
des entrepreneurs
en tant que dirigeants chefs
d'entreprise on a tous eu à négocier des
lignes de crédit à signer des cautions
personnelles donc c'est une matière
qu'on a vécu un petit peu concrètement
dans notre cher et donc ce que vont
vivre les chefs d'entreprise ou ce
qu'ils vivent on sait tout à fait ce que
ça représente est ce que ça peut
représenter et pour la société mais
également pour le dirigeant de la
société qui attend et qui ensuite
peut-être revoir le jugement changer le
cours de sa vie
[Musique]
nous a confié une mission qu'on a
accepté l'année être parfois le dessus
viande entre sait qu'elle va un tour de
conséquences parfois une décision
condamnant une entreprise que scellait
définitivement le sort de cette
entreprise malheureusement ce n'est pas
un argument qui fait que ça puisse
influencer notre jugement
alors monsieur le commissaire très
rapidement comme vous l'avez précisé
nous avons évoqué ce dossier plusieurs
reprises devant votre juridiction la
société d'anti des questions exploite
une activité de cafés restaurants et
cette société en a un passif total
aujourd'hui qui est estimé à un million
deux cent mille euros et donc le la
société dans un contexte elle ne pouvait
plus faire face je commençais ap 1000
euros par mois
il dit qu'il ya là confirmant le papil
1000 euros
j'étais allé demander l'aide pendant les
confirmands parce que tout le monde est
là il m'a dit non vous êtes en mode est
à vous n'avez pas de trois heures de
cette aide voilà ici pour ça que je suis
là je sais pas mais c'est la crise
sanitaire markovits 19 qui vous a
empêché d'honorer ses remboursements
auprès des services fiscaux que vous en
auriez depuis plusieurs années et
ensuite quelques loyer également ce sont
les loyers j'ai circulé de logiciels
confirme
j'ai tiré jours avec le loyer pendant le
valent bien sûr si le loyer d'heure le
moniteur qui ferment
monsieur libre c'est donc vous nous
confirmez donc vous n'avez pas
l'activité de vente de boissons
alcoolisées et que pour la poursuite de
l'activité de votre entreprise vous
n'avez pas de nécessité a gardé cette
licence oui très bien d'où votre volonté
de la cd de façon à alléger le passif de
votre entreprise
est-ce que vous avez un autre
commentaire à nous faire
d'accord rien à ajouter de plus
merci pour cet exposé nous aurons une
date de délibéré au 27 septembre
[Musique]
je
suis un des rôles essentiels du
juge-commissaire aussi c'est d'avoir
une mission je dirais pas de
vulgarisation en tout cas de rendre
intelligible la procédure pour le
débiteur ses terres qu'il faut qu'ils
comprennent exactement ce qui lui arrive
alors des fois il faut même l'aider à
savoir pourquoi ils se retrouvent et se
retrouve ici et ensuite il faut qu'ils
comprennent bien qu'on n'est pas là pour
lui trancher la tête mais simplement
nous notre objectif c'est de savoir
est-ce qu'il ya encore des ressources
humaines matérielles
commercial et c'est pourquoi
l'entreprise perdure
[Musique]
bonjour madame
on
bonjour
numéro 10
c'est à voir 3905 2,44 euros à titre qui
roule à faire
2e créances pour un montant de 160 3500
32,52 euros
et enfin 20 numéros 20 pour un montant
de 2067 au calme à ses atours
longtemps mûri en tant que voyagiste
l'époque en était
on avait une notoriété nationale puisque
toutes nos clients étaient les agences
de voyages de france sept au départ
c'est un événement tout à fait fortuit
et externes qui n'est pas de mon fait
que tu fait qu'on a perdu les accords
pour pouvoir continuer à travailler je
me suis retrouvé donc du jour au
lendemain je dis bien du jour au
lendemain avec tous les écrans noirs
plus pouvoir travailler est impossible
de vous faire face aux demandes des
clients impossible de continuer de
travailler donc c'est pour ça que je
veux c'est retrouver en situation de
liquidation des sociétés et pourquoi on
est là au bout de x années bientôt dix
ans donc c'est très long et moi j'ai
tout perdu vraiment tout perdu et c'est
vrai que le chef d'entreprise ne ce
n'est pas toujours se retrouvent de
quelques fois dans des situations très
compliqué très complexes auxquelles ni
s'attend pas du tout puisque tout
fonctionne bien et que du jour au
lendemain pas se retrouver
dans des grottes très très grosses
difficultés parce qu'après tout
s'enchaîne tout s'enchaîne plus de
milieu social plus de vie
professionnelle plus de revenus aussi
puisque mes revenus venait de mes
sociétés des cautions à gérer
tout ça fait que c'est
donc ils ont c'est l'engrenage infernal
dans lequel se trouve le chef
d'entreprise le quant au départ il ya
volonté de continuer son activité de
continuer à travailler parce que la
société tam à 38 ans d'existence donc
faut tenir bon mais c'est vrai que en ce
qui me concerne je vais très très mal
vécu puisque ça va provoquer un cancer
je ne dormais plus je vais plus dans
l'angoissé de voir un huissier passer
tous les jours à la maison très
compliqué quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
souvent le chef d'entreprise et des
seuls et isolés par rapport à ça parce
que c'est difficile en temps parler une
perte d'image aussi de confiance en soi
quand il se retrouve dans la tourmente
ils sont isolés mais ici lol eux-mêmes
non pas qu'ils sont rejetés par les
autres mais de fait le premier réflexe
qu'ils ont c'est de s'isoler eux mêmes
et ce après ça en chêne difficultés
financières qui vont entraîner des
difficultés familiales personnelles même
des fois parfois de deux logements etc
donc ça peut être parfois difficile et
les débiteurs qui se présente devant un
tribunal de commerce sont parfois
dans des états je dirais
fragile et
il ya un vrai impact sur la défaillance
de leur société sur leur vie qui peut
être anéanti complètement
[Musique]
on va faire une collection de courtes et
printemps ce que je suis c'est chef
d'entreprise avant tout moi ce que
j'aime c'est développer j'aime la
rentabilité j'aime le challenge
j'aime la compétition
c'est ça que c'est ça qu'il s'est fait
un bon moteur ça a toujours été ça j'ai
monté des entreprises spécialisées on va
grandir en groupe dans le marketing et
la communication du luxe
et il ya quatre ans j'ai décidé de créer
une marque de vêtements parce que
j'avais envie de créer
donc j'ai lancé cette marque qui
s'appelle follement classique
[Musique]
cette année
malheureusement
alors on peut vivre les choses les
boutiques jeu sincèrement elles sont
toutes au bourg ouvre
deux ans d'existence follement placide
ont un nom qu'on a mais russe égale
extraordinaire comme de toute façon vous
vous êtes en chômage partiel et
heureusement merci heureusement que ça
existe eh ben on va moins vite que
d'habitude mais on y va quand même
[Musique]
mon
ma société aussi est fragile je suis du
même côté que ceux qui viennent au
tribunal de commerce je comprends leurs
difficultés mais c'est aussi pour ça que
j'ai eu envie de m'engager pour les
aider à s'en sortir
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais siéger pour la
première fois en tant que juge cela
faisait longtemps que je n'avais pas
ressenti l'excitation d'une rentrée des
classes
quelle fierté de revêtir cette robe mais
bien sûr et j'ai encore tout à apprendre
bonjour
fois oui oui je suis arrivé un peu en
avance assez bien le stress dès la
première fois la première fois c'est
bien tu sais que tu n'as pas le droit
mais interrompre l'audience il faut que
à chaque pendant pendant l'audience se
situe à des questions à poser
tu l'as fait passer à temps assesseurs
kaki à côté de toi d'accord dp kim le
transmettra voilà donc tu prends des
notes quand le maximum de notre temps
bon alors
là par exemple qu'est ce qu'on va avoir
comme le type de secteur d'activité il
ya beaucoup d'activités construction en
fait il est une chambre spécialisée dans
la construction ge spécialisée dans la
construction puisque moi je suis je suis
du bâtiment on one je dirigerai mais ses
chaînes c'est justement on va
t'apprendre
bonjour factice un paquebot ne sais pas
catherine catherine la nouvelle la
nouvelle juge dieu merci je vais vous
regarder je vais vous écoutez c'est
parfait bienvenue merci merci beaucoup
ouais ça va être très très intéressant
mais c'est vrai que au début on essaye
surtout de pas faire de bêtises en fait
c'est surtout salle
donc tu peux pas en faire des bêtises au
début non j'ai bien compris ce que tu es
et tu vas rester tranquille qui va
écouter mais c'est ce que exactement
c'est ce que j'ai prévu ok on y va
il
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
entre 6 et 12 deux semaines le métrage
où il est passé le pièce de janvier mais
ça c'est marthe est nulle part facile le
championnat mais quand j'ai été livré le
14 mars logiquement une semaine après
tout devait être fini comprenez monsieur
va vous voir aujourd'hui s'affranchir de
ses obligations contractuelles et du
paiement qui doit la société les
affaires souvent très techniques
s'enchaînent toute la matinée dans notre
chambre qui se réunit tous les lundis on
s'occupe du contentieux c'est à dire des
litiges entre différentes entreprises ou
entre associés d'autres jugent en
procédure collective sont eux spécialisé
dans les sociétés en difficulté
disposition de l'a380 8 du code de
procédure civile cette demande visant à
constater la péremption est il recevable
sur les 388 qui prévoit des temps calmes
enquête soit menée à bien mais sauf que
ce temps que la péremption d'instance
d'époque qu'ils je ne vois pas comment
je pourrais soulever ce moyen des ségas
ce que j'ai ici j'ai donné la lecture de
l'article 2 du protocole lors dire que
c'était sans aucune reconnaissance de
responsables y ont su soit de rigueur
mais le tribunal a bien compris je porte
d'accord troisième étape du raisonnement
c'est l'opposabilité du protocole
d'accord transactionnel
c'est époustouflant
messieurs le médoc du tribunal ça ne
tient pas debout ce raisonnement merci m
délibéré 19 avril on se croirait dans
une pièce de théâtre
chacun est dans son rôle les
entrepreneurs qui peuvent se défendre
seul pour les affaires de moins de 10000
euros sont un peu groggy les avocats
veulent convaincre la greffière note
tout et nous les juges nous écoutons et
nous devons rendre une décision
alors 4e plus impression bas mes
impressions
on comprend pourquoi il faut prendre des
notes
parce que sinon on se perd vite dans la
chronologie quand les affaires sont
croisés quand vous aurez souvent et
surtout au début quand tu as le premier
avocat qui plaide tu dis monsieur clair
ça va il a raison et puis tiens tant le
deuxième avocat
après qu'il va plaider et là tu te dis à
metz mais nommé lui aussi la région et
c'est là où tu y as le doute
mais si après la lecture des pièces que
tu vas te convaincre la personne qui
aura raison mais en fait là on va
délibérer donc on va déjà prendre une
décision sur les dossiers oui donc ça
veut dire que ensuite quand on va
étudier les pièces à fond peut avoir une
vision différente du dossier absolument
quand je te le dis la décision est
collégiale c'est pas une personne qui
prend une décision c'est pour ça qu'on
est 5 ou 3 en nommant pairs d'accor
toute façon on te donnera des petits
dossiers et puis on les corrigera avec
toi donc comme ça petit à petit tu as tu
vas à vraiment bon alors la première
affaire on va prendre la plus compliquée
la plus longue
[Musique]
bonjour genre
donc chez nous au sérieux c'est ça
c'est le numéro siret alors les chiffres
qui sont après votre numéro siren c'est
ça qui change ok
et voilà
ça c'est le comme quoi les faire mais ça
c'est votre caviste du goût qui
mentionne qu'à lui la dissolution
justement à compter de 2020 donc la smat
société considérée comme radier d'accord
je perds je vous en prie ce rebond
donc soit on fait les démarches auprès
des impôts directement vouloir expliquer
le problème et vous en baisse pour
change de régime fiscal la peur qui est
quasiment impossible un jeu pour lui si
ouais ouais ah oui en fait il ya un
doublon vous avez deux sociétés
c'est toujours la même société et vous
n'avez pas de faire correctement les
démarches quand vous avez transférer le
siège et de mort je mens que mon
comptable au début et
j'ai les publications de l'époque
étaient
entassés au jardin parce que je trouve
du travail c'est mon maxi marin
alors en fait je viens de déposer les
comptes ouais j'ai quatre années à
déposer d'accord à titre d'information
l'exercice 2016 n'a jamais fait déposer
2016 aussi mais c'est ce que je me dis
ok c'est ça ouais l'exercice 2016 il ya
une relance qui a été fait maintenant on
n'a pas convoqué on s'en occupe voilà
le
c'est un univers que je connais pas et
c'est en cela qu'il existe un vrai
challenge parce que là pour le coup on
peut pas mentir on est obligé d'aller se
mettre dans les boues cas d'essayer de
comprendre de rédiger deux d'être
extrêmement rigoureux
intellectuellement bah oui c'est
passionnant bah oui parce que c'est très
compliqué c'est pas facile
tant que je ne suis pas suffisamment
formés en fait je pourrais pas dire
que j'ai l'impression de servir à
quelque chose en fait donc je pense déjà
qu'il faut vraiment que je me forme
beaucoup que j'apprenne que je lise et
quand j'aurais fait ça là je pourrais
dire
là je pense qu effectivement je peux
servir de quelque chose pour l'instant
j'apprends
on passe à la procédure qu'est ce que
c'est la procédure c'est que de marde le
demandeur et que demande le défendeur
c'est pareil que les demandes alors la
place et la procédure et les prétentions
mais les demandes c'est pareil n'est pas
pareil et on appelle ça un patient alors
on appelle ça la procédure alors que la
da qui appelle ça la procédure car la
capelle saint les prétentions et
personne n'appelle ça les demandes et il
y en a qui appelle ça les deux bornes
j'avais mis un petit peu de vocabulaire
juridique l'aca aussi un soyez vigilants
décret ou est d'arrêter il dispose
je bats il vit de son délibéré le
tribunal a prononcé des juges bord la
cour d'appel en des arts est pas d
arrêter d arrêt on se pourvoit en
cassation on interjette appel aux
demandeurs le défendeur par le défenseur
des panthers
qu'est ce que vous ressentez 400 t de
l'audience l'un est ce que il arrive que
l'impression que vous aviez un sortir de
l'audience soit battue en brèche par le
délibéré on ou délibérée ou par
l'opinion de vos collègues qui gueulait
qui ont vu les choses que j'aurais mon
opération et qui du coup s'ils sont plus
fort mais aussi dans votre chambre nous
on est un peu oui on est forcément rizla
de complexe d'infériorité non non ils
sont plus formés mais pas de conseils a
perdu 8 et vous avez la même voie il n'y
a pas de voie pépin de nord fait
d'accord mais il n'y a pas de voix
prépondérante
vous avez votre votre impression elle
est important dossier est allé même
d'autant plus importante qu'elle est
détaché d'une pratique voilà est
intéressante à ce titre c'est vrai que
le droit le droit ne dit pas tout quand
même par exemple sur le mois j'ai eu
faim un cas là de caution avertis ou non
averti pour aller vraiment définir ce
que c'est qu'une caution avertis ou non
averti on peut voir les choses de
différentes manières soit d'accord et là
il ya quand même même si c'est pas de
l'équité c'est du discernement je ne
sais pas comment on appelle ça mais les
avocats sont des conteurs de compteurs
qui parlent bien les sondés copter vous
vendu de théorie et ils vont ils vous
vendent de la théorie d'autant plus
volontiers que vous n'êtes pas des juges
professionnels un
don qui n'ont pas affaire à des juges de
métiers qui sont là qui est toute la
journée dans l'offre et qui ne s'en
laissent plus conter et vous devez
prendre des décisions et vous devez
rendre de décision c'est ça on peut pas
dire écoutez je ne sais pas repartez
aller voir quelqu'un d'autre je suis pas
capable de vous donner la décision ça
s'appelle un déni de justice d'interdire
tout à fait trouvé la décision alors il
ya des moyens pour la trouver
mais vous devez là vous devez rendu
décision cet oubli la loi vous en fait
obligation
je voulais dit déjà un le secret c'est
dans l'examen du dossier vous je pense
que vous avez convaincu aujourd'hui
vous allez commencer votre travail il va
commencer pas à la sortie de l'audience
jusque là on a fait de la figuration
grandes amies la robe et chapeau à
écouter on n'a pas travaillé après les
autres leur boss commence à bosser et ça
ça demande du travail voilà du travail
mais si on est on va moins vite il faut
travailler un peu plus voilà il faut y
arriver y'a pas n'y a pas d'issue
le jeu
les assignations en redressement
judiciaire les clôtures et l'aider ville
entre rappeler au dernier étage tout le
monde reste en bas y compris les
requêtes du coup
retenir
ou inconnus
vont arriver là on a ensuite laurent
vers blut je suis chef d'entreprise et
mon métier à part entière et d'être
expert comptable et commissaire aux
comptes
conseil
monsieur le procureur bonjour
je pense que le tribunal en son nom est
déjà un mot qui peut effrayer
un certain nombre de personnes qui
viennent ici ne sont jamais venus avant
peuvent être impressionné donc il faut
qu'on intègre la nuit blanche que ces
gens ont certainement dû passer quand
ils sont convoqués devant un tribunal
[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde
merci
en fait il faut comprendre notre
démarche comme vous ne déposez pas les
comptes 17 18 19 et 20 il y avait
vraisemblablement une injonction c'est à
dire quelqu'un vous a demandé de payer
vous ne l'avez pas payer ça laisse
penser il y a peut être un problème dans
votre entreprise autre question
aujourd'hui donc vous avez une suspicion
d'état de sa tion des paiements vous
êtes en suspicion d'être en état de
cessation des paiements c'est à dire ne
plus pouvoir payer mes fournisseurs
courant la dette courant fiscales et
sociales clair là dessus
donc aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est
nous apporter la preuve écrite matériel
que vous n'êtes pas dans cette situation
des taxations des paiements or comment
le démontrent je viens avec des
attestations fiscales ursa j'ai un
expert comptable qui m'écrit noir sur
blanc et ça suffirait mon client la
société n'est pas en état station dément
pas prévu tous ces documents là mais je
pense que la majorité peuvent être
obtenus alors direct donc monsieur
procurant renvoie dans quinze jours
23 septembre vous n'aurez pas de
convocations attention
notez tout de suite vous à 8h30 je
viendrai vous apportez un document que
vous m'avez demandé voilà
parfait on vous souhaite une bonne
journée je vous merci aussi au revoir
là encore les comptes annuels n'ont pas
été déposées au tribunal de commerce et
surtout aucune vision sur sur l'état de
l'entreprise ce qui est un critère
supplémentaire qui laisse à penser que
le dirigeant se désintéresse de
l'activité de l'entreprise enfin en tout
cas de ses difficultés
j'attends qu'ils puissent nous rassurer
sur
l'état financier de l'entreprise surtout
nous apporter des éléments qui
permettent d'établir qu'il n'est pas en
état de cessation des paiements
en fait tant
dans la provocation convoqué par e-mail
et montez pas convoqué à la bonne
adresse mais c'est excusez moi monsieur
lurçat vous a convoqué oui ces trottoirs
ou convoque t-il pour vérification des
déclarations pour un contrôle c'est ça
points de contrôle pour un contrôle
urssaf points de contrôles traditionnels
ces sommes d'accord et vous avez eu un
redressement oui le corner j'ai pas la
somme exacte mais je pense c'est dans
les
180 milles à peu près 180 les 180 vous
pouvez les payer je ne peux pas été
d'accord donc aujourd'hui la question
qu'on se pose aujourd'hui c'est est-ce
que entre tout ce que vous devez et
l'argent dont vous disposez
vous avez plus de dette que d'argent des
dettes que l'argent vous est ce qu'on
appelle juridiquement en état de
cessation des paiements c'est simple
c'est ça vous en convenez c'est d'accord
y compris donc vous allez plus
perspectives d'activité de toute façon
plus
vraiment le travail en tant que le
qu'employé non hadopi alors c'est là où
on doit décider avec vous est-ce qu on
part sur une liquidation judiciaire ou
un redressement judiciaire
pour être honnête avec vous je n'ai pas
de plan de redressement
merci de votre honnêteté donc on
partirait sur un lit selon vos propos
sur une liquidation judiciaire
bon vous avez compris que le suspense
sera léger
donc on partirait sur une liquidation
dit général j'ai aucun employé mais ça
doit être très rapide
tout en étant général
voilà je vous souhaite une bonne journée
et le jour
les libérés la semaine prochaine le 16
dans ce parcours
est-ce qu'on a une lourde responsabilité
oui on a une lourde responsabilité
[Musique]
parfois c'est extrêmement simple c'est
basique c'est oui c'est non mais quand
on vous demande
dans des cadres de sanction de
dirigeants de dire ses 15 ans
d'interdiction de gérer ses 7 ans et 8
ans ces trois cent mille euros d'amendé
50000 euros damende oui c'est une lourde
responsabilité
donc effectivement on a une plume qui
engagent des salariés des vies de
dirigeants des cautions donc oui on a
une responsabilité
moi ça m'est arrivé de d'avoir eu une
année où j'ai dû prendre des décisions
qui étaient décision de dur de sanctions
qui était à l'encontre de ce que j'aime
c'est à dire permettre à l'entreprise de
se redresser mais il fallait le faire un
passif aujourd'hui ce sont 36 euros
le positif et pouvait avoir un dirigeant
à qui on reproche un certain nombre de
fautes de gestion qui a fait que sa
société est partie en liquidation
judiciaire et que l'état les
fournisseurs les caisses sociales n'ont
pas été payés elle a les arguments les
contextes de vie peuvent rentrer en
ligne de compte
vous traiterez peut-être je dis bien
peut-être différemment quelqu'un qui a
une grave maladie qui n'a pas pu
s'occuper pendant six mois de son
entreprise ou qu'elle eut un problème
dans sa famille d'un enfant d'une
campagne de quelqu'un et qui de manière
délibérée l'a fait simplement pour
s'enrichir
l'effet déconfinement ont eu un impact
sur la trésorerie du débiteur de la
société
cette procédure était suivie par
beaucoup d'attention voire votre
tribunal la procédure a permis le
règlement des dettes au fur et à mesure
des années aujourd'hui nous sommes en
mesure de payer l'intégralité du passif
sans demande donc au règlement anticipé
de notre passif et qu'il soit mis fin à
cette procédure de femmes à porter ses
fruits m merci c'était clair monsieur le
dirigeant je crois qu'aujourd'hui
début je suis venu à trouville audience
aujourd'hui c'est la dernière tout va
bien j'espère de parvenir on croit et le
tribunal est fier et se félicite d'avoir
des entreprises comme vous combative et
qui peuvent en plus être
sorti d'affaires avant la date limite
donc vous aurez délibéré le 16 septembre
je vous souhaite une bonne journée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc bonjour à toutes et bienvenue au
tribunal de commerce ici le visiteur est
accueilli donc vous envoûter par temis
déesse de la loi de la justice et de
l'équité donc elle tient dans sa main
gauche la loi est encore une fois on
retrouve le glaive saut vol donc de la
sanction ici sur mon psy vous verrez
nous avons encore un caducée sur les
périls
on entend bien par là que
la justice mène à la paix les anciens
présidents verte
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la salle d'audience du
tribunal de commerce
cette salle d'audience impressionne pas
grandeur
c'est la première fois que le tribunal
de commerce est ouvert aux journées du
patrimoine parce que justement on veut
un peu
dé diaboliser le tribunal je veux dire
le tribunal s'est pas
c'est aussi le gardien du bon ordre
économique on n'est pas des censeurs on
est des chefs d'entreprise ont c'est
pour ça que j'ai assisté aussi par
rapport à ça c'est qu'on est des chefs
d'entreprise donc les problématiques des
gens qui sont ici ce sont nos
problématiques au quotidien donc
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va essayer
de trouver une solution pour que
l'entreprise puisse poursuivre son
activité dans le cadre d'un plan de
redressement et si la liquidation
essayer de retrouver un repreneur qui va
reprendre des contrats de travail qui va
reprendre en droit au bail etc
mais par contre si on a un champion du
monde du redressement judiciaire comme
on en a certains terrains certains cdd
sportif du genre quand même si tous les
quatre ans si tous les cinq ans si tous
les dix ans il plante 10 fournisseurs y
plante 10 sous traitants où il paie pas
ses dettes c'est un risque pour toute
notre activité ces gens là donc là on a
des sanctions et on a des sanctions qui
sont fortes c'est aussi notre rôle c'est
aussi un rôle de censeur sur ces gens
qui sont des perturbateurs du monde
économique jeune entreprise qui viennent
pour délibéré tout ça ils peuvent pas
avoir des désavantages à favoriser un
jeu d'entreprise
commencent à se
terrer comme vous le soulignez vous êtes
tous des chefs d'entreprise est une
question qui est intéressante à la salle
est déjà arrivé par exemple ici
j'avais la présidence de la chambre et
puis arrive arrive un dossier et il se
trouve que le dossier qui m'arrive
c'était le dossier un dossier de mon
principal concurrent alors je peux dire
tiens bonne pioche je vais le prendre et
puis on va voir aujourd'hui de façon
très claire déontologiquement
jeudi à la greffière ont fait une
suspension d'audience on se voit
derrière j'ai dit voilà moi ce dossier
je ne peux pas le prendre en deux
solutions soit quelqu'un peut me
remplacer à l'audience et je me rends
place je je je sors de la composition du
tribunal soit et c'est en général ce
qu'on préfère faire pour qui et pas du
tout de suspicion c'est dire on ne prend
pas le dossier ici on le renvoie sur une
autre chambre
si je vous dis
je
aujourd'hui je suis vice présidente du
tribunal je siège le lundi enfin je suis
présente au tribunal le lundi toute la
journée le mercredi matin le jeudi matin
je ne suis pas dans mon entreprise je ne
suis pas payé
je consacre du temps
parfois le week end
vous allez me dire mais
c'est quoi votre intérêt lane dans un
très bonne question donc tout de suite
on touche à une matière qui est une
matière économique donc on se dit mon
mac qui dit économie dit brassage de
transaction du honoraire et c est en
face vous avez des magistrats qui sont
là et qui font ça pour la gloire donc
tout de suite on a cette suspicion là
pourquoi vous faites ça parce que ça me
plaît parce que sinon je le ferai pas
parce que je pense qu'il ya un vrai
plaisir il ya un vrai plaisir à aller à
l'été étudier un texte qui vient de
sortir
allez comprendre pourquoi une de nos
décisions a été infirmée en appel où est
ce qu'on s'est planté qu'est ce qu'on
n'a pas vu
et toutes ces choses là c'est un vrai
c'est un vrai plaisir intellectuel on
vient ici pour
aider les entreprises pour
être vrai tribunal de nos affaires
économiques locales c'est important pour
nous
et donc je veux dire le sort du chef
d'entreprise c'est aussi le nôtre donc
cédric tout s'entremêle un petit peu
voilà
[Musique]
moi dit un peu sinistré est folle et
path écho si ça fait trois ans que ça
existe un follement classique donc déjà
pour une marque qui se lance c'est pas
simple donc je sais pas ce que ça aurait
donné si elle n'est pas hulk au but mais
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'avec le coc bin
ça va pas arranger les choses
je suis typiquement dans la réalité
d'une toute petite entreprise en fait
qui vient de se créer et qui essayent de
surnager et voilà oui
je savais très bien que ce serait
difficile à toute façon je sais que
c'est difficile donc j'en suis là en
fait je suis un peu tout seul
pour me sentir moins seul une fois par
mois je participe à la réunion de
l'association femmes chefs d'entreprises
où l'on échange sur nos réussites et nos
difficultés c'est ce club qui m'a donné
l'envi de postuler au mandat de juge ce
soir je vais leur en parler et j'espère
susciter chez elle des vocations
catherine jeune juge parce que ça fait
moins d'un an que tu as pris donc si tu
devais donner une ou plusieurs qualités
pour répondre à ce poste de juge du
tribunal de commerce pourquoi tu été
choisi parce que je suis une femme non
mais il faut voir les choses c'est bien
la réalité
donc moi c'est comme ça que je le voyais
d'ailleurs je voyais typiquement comment
comme une institution de bourgeois de
province plutôt masculin et où c'est
sympa de dîner entre soi voilà comment
je voyais ça
donc en fait
ils veulent élargir il va ils veulent
vraiment qu'une représentativité
beaucoup plus fort de la réalité des
entreprises et c'est une vraie je pense
qu'une vraie envie de leur part déjà
d'élargir au niveau des secteurs
d'activité donc il faut être chef
d'entreprise il faut avoir envie moi mon
moteur c'est je ne souhaite pas laisser
tout le temps les autres décider à ma
place
ça c'est mon moteur ça je te connais pas
ce que ça vaut le coup qu'on vienne
mettre notre grain de sel c'est notre
voie allemand das notre voie vous de
voir si vous avez envie d'y aller c'est
parce que vous avez envie de dire ce que
vous avez à trier qui a envie de prendre
un mandat
c'est peut-être devenir parent référence
que tu là
mais on a commencé par ça mais j'ai
quatre étoiles oui mais lyon n'a qu'
[Musique]
capable d'en mais nous n'avons
cela fait maintenant presque un an que
je suis juge et je commence à être plus
à l'aise dans ma robe je commence à
comprendre ce que l'on attend de moi
[Musique]
bon c'est la justice humaine moi quand
je suis arrivé j'avais l'impression que
je ne comprenais pas vraiment pourquoi
on avait besoin absolument d'être
humains ou tout ça je pensais que
c'était tellement des critères objectifs
qu'on jugeait pour tracy n'est pas
signée des conditions générales de vente
qui sont ce qu'elles sont voilà donc
j'ai oublié mais finalement mois au
mieux tout ça qu'est-ce que pourquoi on
a besoin d'un être humain au milieu de
tout ça et au fur et à mesure je
commence à comprendre pourquoi dire que
c'est vrai qu'il ya des vrais ya des
vrais moments où en fait c c'est à nous
deux
de décider en fonction de notre âme et
conscience en fait il faut faire
attention d'être juste en fait et c'est
bien ça le problème qu'est ce que ça
veut dire être juste et c'est pour ça
que je pense que c'est important
effectivement qui est des juges qui
viennent de tous horizons qu'il ya des
hommes et des femmes qui est des gens de
tous les âges
de tous les secteurs d'activité en fait
chacun avec son histoire va juger
peut-être pas complètement différemment
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des fois où on
peut interpréter les choses d'une
manière ou d'une autre c'est vrai par
exemple j'ai une fille qui à 25 ans une
fille qui à 23 ans est ce que j'ai la
même attitude que quelqu'un qui est plus
âgée ou qui a pas le même parcours que
moi où il ya pas d enfant j'en sais rien
mais je pense que c'est ça que veut la
justice et c'est que c'est ça qu'on
n'entend pas remettre de l'humanité dans
la justice en fait
[Musique]
ce
oh
[Musique]